je rentrais venez venez manger ma
voiture donnez moi non mais vous êtes
dans une émission qu'est-ce qui se passe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va
à travers vous dans tout ça n'est pas
très cher et on a on a un truc à faire
je croyais qu'il y ait ce qui se passe
on me dit on me dit qu'il ya quelqu'un
qui se passe on vous entend pas rentrer
entrées durant très bonne et venez
manger ma voiture venait non mais vous
vous êtes dans une émission qu'est-ce
qui se passe il ya un camion corse avec
un camion blanc qui s'est collé à moi
pas la question pressé je dois partir à
qui appartient ce camion bloque avec les
immatriculations corse c'est quoi comme
camion c'est un jumpy un jam et terry
citroën va être quelqu'un qui a un job
chez citroën
vous messieurs venez là on va rester
dans votre charme papa c'est moi c'était
la voiture de votre papa c'est facile à
voir si elle est mal garées bah je sais
pas on va les voir
attendez vous y venez on va les mener
venez avec moi avec moi venez venez avec
moi
venez avec moi oh la la venez là ça
devient n'importe quoi cette émission il
ya des mecs sont mal garées rend tout ça
c'est n'importe quoi venait que moi on
va vous réglez ça monsieur venez venez
là oui bon ben ça va c'est bon c'est
quoi ces cinq camions oui c'est ça le
camion mais ce que est ce que c'est
votre camion ouais c'est le cas même si
réd gameiro monsieur qu'est ce qui se
passe qu'est ce qui s'est passé ben en
fait ne va pas il s'est fait voler tous
ces outils dans son camion ouais je t'ai
fait de vidéo pour essayer de lui
ordonner au moins tous les outils qu'il
a perdue pour qu'il puisse travailler
parce qu'il peut pas travailler ce que
vous savez pourquoi vous êtes là bas
maintenant je me dis si j'avais un
problème avec votre camion on vous a
volé tous vos outils bombes allaient
chérie je crois compte si vous pouvez
l'ouvrir a les yeux ouvrez le nouvel
canaux merci bon bah je crois qu'on veut
je crois qu'on vous a fait tout ce qu'on
vous a mis tous les outils mais chérie
tu crois qu'on vous a mis tous les midis
merci c'est pour mousser cadeaux voilà
messieurs vous avez tous les outils vous
allez pouvoir retravailler chez
des techniciens c'est une galère pour
vous et je bosse fils ou pouvais
l'embrasser art est un super garçon qui
nous envoyer ou égaux ça nous a beaucoup
beaucoup louche et ils sont tous
et voilà je sent l'ail non ce sont quand
même merci mr sont comportés avec le
camion d'atouts dedans vous allez
pouvoir bosser cette fois vraiment tout
c'est ici que ça fait une semaine toit
aux galères et on vous aime ce sport
et bravo votre fils qu un super gars
merci mes chéris ton
[Musique]